I think it's very important to let the
research lead teaching the reason is the
following for many other business
schools the flow of information is they
observe what industry is doing right now
and then they study it as a researchers
and then they in the classroom they
justify why they are doing it but at a
Carnegie Mellon we do completely the
opposite way so we first talked to the
industry we observe what is going to
happen in the future with the industry
practice and then as a researchers we
are encouraged to study to solve to
develop the cutting-edge business
solutions and then we disseminate the
research result to our students then our
students will serve as ambassadors they
go out to the industry they try to tell
the other managers what can be done